we'll economic power Willard's almost  stolen  [Applause]  the state survives and wins Game two  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  willing come back with for Golden State  a gut-wrenching loss report he played  more during the year with the first tee  ball defense because when it matters  most  this guy has food with the piece and  elite all-time defender  great hands the strip seals the victory  outstanding defense by Andre Iguodala :  State was down 17 early in the game  and then they were down again by 8 with  just under four and a half remaining as  Andre Iguodala runs and celebration back  to the locker room a 14 to 3 run in the  last point